good afternoon the newest resort in las
vegas it just opened up and honestly
it's
quite a remarkable site isn't it though
yeah awesome so thank you so much for
joining
us on destination vegas i'm christian
gosselin and i'm kirsten joyce we do
appreciate you joining us this afternoon
we've got a lot to talk about
including the fact that the resort
behind us is just a few of the many
exciting things happening as las vegas
emerges
out of the pandemic over the next half
hour we'll share the places that are
helping las vegas become a top travel
destination
with activities not only for tourists
but locals as well
it's a las vegas spot not many people
know of yet
museum of selfies opened its doors just
a couple months ago
here's a look inside this trendy venue
hey guys we're inside the museum of
selfies it's a brand new venue on the
las vegas strip
that'll force your imagination to go
wild
from giant edible bites to a selfie
stick made thrown
the museum of selfies in las vegas is
getting more than likes from visitors
we feel like a kid like i'm a kid all
over again
the venue located along the linc
promenade recently launched as the
second in its franchise
but according to its creator it's one of
a kind every museum is a little bit
different we had a lot of like
traditional museums when you can go
and see different like stuff but they
never allow you to touch
things play with them do something cool
right so and we decided that we have to
create something different from that
you can snap a picture in this lavish
jet while pretending to drink champagne
as you fly into las vegas or do several
clicks on your camera phone
while bathing in this royal tub filled
with gold coins
one of my favorites this flipped bedroom
keep your hand
in the middle of this table this is your
leg and you will move it like this
one two three perfect we will
edit this picture handstand how cool is
that
yeah the museum also claims to have the
first
selfie ever taken and documented i have
a lot of like artifacts
from like uh you know for example like
1835 the very first selfie
which was taken the same way as we do
right now
robert cornelius did that using the same
way
mirror in front huge camera because that
time the cameras were so huge
right and he took a selfie the same way
as we do right now
summer has officially begun and that
means you're probably looking for the
perfect place to chill out
we have that place for you icebar at the
link promenade has got you covered
it just underwent renovations and
reopened with a whole new look
the owner says it's a fun experience for
the entire family
the kids love to come out in the
summertime we get families of all kinds
inside
i wish we could do snowball fights
inside unfortunately
that's not the case but it sure is fun
to take the opportunity with this
weather
to have some fun bowman says the most
enjoyable part is creating a winter
wonderland in the middle of the mojave
desert
and the best part too guests may never
have the same experience twice
did you know that las vegas is home to
the world's largest observation wheel
the high roller at the link stands at
550 feet
which is a full 107 feet higher than the
london eye
each ride on the high roller lasts 30
minutes offers some pretty incredible
panoramic views of the strip it's
definitely one of the best instagram
spots in las vegas
the best time to go on the high roller
is of course at night while many are
used to the las vegas lights the shows
and even the amazing foods
the waldorf astoria is the first hotel
to bring back
a classic but elegant experience located
on the 23rd floor that's where you will
find the tea lounge
a memorable spot
t is just going to get more traction
this space really lets you
experience vegas from an eagle eye
standpoint chintan daddych is waldorf
astoria's general manager he says t
service started 10 years ago providing a
unique experience
when you come to vegas when you think of
las vegas afternoon tea is not the first
thing that comes to mind
but this elegant afternoon tea an
amazing view has been a popular
attraction
for not just tourists but locals too we
start with array of teas
that are that are offered to you
multiple infusions
multiple flavors and tea experts take
you through the menu
next comes the culinary delights that
are then paired with your tea service
from oolong tea to flowery arrow gray
and even cherry blossom you will find
yourself finding tranquility
in a cup of tea that obviously comes
with uh
you know coloring delights such as
macaroons that are paired perfectly with
them
there's tea sandwiches which are
decadent
and if you're looking for the perfect
photo opportunity this tea lounge has
you covered
right from the time you get to the hotel
from our front drive
to the gold wall on the 23rd level and
this beautiful view here in t
lounge as well as the sky bar next to it
we are absolutely instagram friendly
even adding a unique vending machine for
some bubbly
salijaramillo reporting on the las vegas
strip
[Music]
this experience welcomes all ages prices
are 58 dollars for adults and 30 dollars
for kids now reservations are
recommended three to four weeks
in advance baby birds cafe in las vegas
near sahara and durango has been in
business for about three years
it's bringing more than just coffee to
the las vegas valley it's got plenty to
offer
it's the las vegas desert but when you
come in here it feels like your relaxing
backyard
supa kayala panak is baby bird cafe's
owner she says after traveling around
the globe she discovered a love for
visiting
cute cafes since las vegas is the
entertainment capital of the world she
wanted to bring something cute
classy and healthy from coffee to
smoothies
tea healthy toast and even acai bowls
there's vegan and gluten-free options as
well
when the mother bird feed the baby bird
it's got to be good thing right
yeah and healthy like you eat something
good and make you
light like you can fly like a baby bird
but also i think about
nature in addition to the delicious and
very pretty looking food items you can
find here
it's also instagram friendly thanks to
their flower wall
mountain and lake views a born and
raised las vegas concept founded back in
2010.
fukuburger started as a restaurant but
it failed because of the economy
it was then revamped as a food truck
it's an all-american burger with a
japanese twist
fuku means luck a term shared by
japanese and chinese
aside from their distinctive and very
delicious burger menu
you can find artwork that involves
japanese toys
and anime along with 80s and 90s
retroprints
fuku burger owner colin fukunaga says
whether you're a foodie or just an
instagram blogger
this is the place for you the most
popular
uh from like the like the foodie
standpoint the people that are coming
usually to us to try something different
than the regular burger is the number
two which is a tamago burger it means
egg in japanese
it's a fried egg over crispy onions
fudokaki seasonings a japanese seasoning
with a homemade teriyaki sauce
fukunagawa says they are not reinventing
the wheel they are just
mixing and matching sweet and savory
ingredients
also showcasing the abilities of what
locals can do
in this beautiful city next on
destination vegas we take you to outdoor
dining on the las vegas strip a look
inside beer park
is coming up a hidden oasis in the
southern highlands area
why many are saying becca's restaurant
and lounge is the place to be
[Music]
it is definitely one of the most unique
places to grab a beer
picture this out on the patio sipping
that beer overlooking the bellagio
fountain
that's right well it really doesn't get
any better than this here's more on that
destination that promises to be
a one-of-a-kind experience
[Music]
i haven't tried this one actually but
great views and great brews here at the
beer park
at the paris it's great it's actually
our first time and
look at the nachos the burger about to
try this but this is really good
the 19 000 square foot second level spot
opened in 2016
but it's pouring much more than beer
host pandemic
we're all about experience here so if
you have a great experience that's
different than anywhere else on the
strip
i think we've won the name itself
attracts thousands to explore its
variety of beers
but the food according to this group we
got the
brisket grilled cheese and the chicken
cheese steak
amazing with misters and fans to cool
you off
this trendy venue is filled with giant
tvs and even has an indoor lounge with a
variety of games
just a sample of why they were voted
best rooftop bar
by thrillist i think it's great i
haven't seen the water show in so long
so right now when it came on i didn't
even realize we were just across the
street from it so that was a great
surprise
[Applause]
well the beer park director tells me
during the day it's a family venue but
at night the energy changes to something
much stronger so check it out las vegas
known for being the entertainment
capital of the world it's also one of
the most instagramable
from colorful dishes to beautiful
scenery sally jaramillo
shows us a one-of-a-kind perspective
[Applause]
becca is kind of our hidden little
secret over here in southern highlands
you can find this gem at the tuscan
highlands apartment community
stephen kennedy is the managing partner
it's a american italian sports bar
with about 34 televisions to watch games
full bar liquor beer draft beer wine
and it also has a 10 000 square foot
patio
lots of amenities here for community
come down and enjoy indoor and outdoor
dining
kennedy and his team wanted to create a
community inside a complex
with an atmosphere that will make you
keep coming back we have a wine garden
that has about
40 tables we have a custom wine cart
that we
built in and brought in from tuscan
italy we host events out there on the
weekends
with some charcuterie and wine and
different
you know specialty cocktails even music
becca
is family friendly and is attracting
tourists
the la commute people are definitely
popping in and catching us on the way
in and on the way out when created this
resort style living bringing
a unique destination to las vegas
beautiful patio views fire pits we have
a little garden wall with
instagram photo opportunity we've got
hand-painted murals inside the venue
but it doesn't stop there in the evening
as the sun sets over the mountain behind
us here it's beautiful
some great photo ops so come down and
get that instagram picture sally
jaramillo reporting from las vegas
becca's restaurant is well known for its
brunch on sundays open from 11
to 1. we're not done yet we have so much
more coming up on destination vegas
it's just a wonderful wonderful picture
how flying over the air has truly taken
momentum in the town of haram
why many are calling this the perfect
kodak moment
if you want to experience the adventure
of a lifetime and see our state like
never before
then this is your chance well this hot
air balloon ride will give you
spectacular views
360 degrees of pahrump as well as the
mountains
[Music]
seemed like every year we were moving a
little bit farther out a little bit
farther out because of the growth and
the development of the city
doug campbell owns las vegas balloon
rices and balloons over perum
he has been in the hot air balloon biz
for 53 years
we kind of discovered perron you know as
far as flying and
paromp is very rural it's very wide open
those who have experienced this
call it magical balloon rides have been
referred to as peaceful
tranquil therapeutic romantic
you know it all depends on what kind of
a moon you're in so how does this
adventure work
depending on the time of year we're
meeting anywhere from five o'clock till
seven o'clock
flying first thing in the morning is
usually the coolest calmest and safest
to inflate a balloon the weight is 15 to
20 minutes
once the balloon stands up we put our
guests in the basket
and then we take off for about 45
minutes to an hour we look at
the west facing side of mount charleston
and we've got the california border is
only about
four miles to the west of us there are
also
several photo opportunities to share
with friends and family the best one
is once we get our guests in the basket
with us we have them turn their cell
phone on selfie mode
and hold it down about waist high and
they'll have
people in their party look overlooked
down into it you're literally
floating um a thousand to two thousand
feet in the air and looking out
you know all over you know god's
creation
sally caramillo reporting from param the
balloon rides
are a shared basket they will set you
back 275 dollars per person
but listen to this pahrump or las vegas
locals get a 50
discount next on destination vegas a
cycle down train tracks this is so much
fun how you can participate in rail
explorers
at any part of the day only 45 minutes
away from las vegas pahrump is becoming
the new tuscany coming up i'll tell you
how to wind up
rail explorers in boulder city has
rolled out its summer program and it's
taking
our hot desert weather into account
we're going to do a 6 30 a.m
sunrise with mimosas we're going to do
this is one of my favorites we're going
to do a super soaker ride
at 8 30 in the morning so it's basically
a water gun fight between
our staff and um uh the riders
so that that's gonna be fun and then
we're gonna close down for the day and
then we're gonna open back up again
at 8pm and do a twilight ride and
then of course it's not vegas without
our neon so we have uh
we've got our bikes all lit up and we've
got a neon ride going out
twice a night rail explorers offers a 10
percent discount for nevada residents
and is launching a promotion in
coordination with fox's barbecue in
boulder city
if you're a first time visitor to parum
the first thing you'll notice is a very
scenic road highway 160.
it's also the shortest distance between
las vegas and death valley
and as sally jaramillo reports it's also
being noticed for something else
[Music]
one of the things that we could do here
in our town to make this
a more tourist attraction is to put a
winery
in 1988 jack sanders owners of sanders
family winery
filed for a federal license to make wine
in nevada
peram valley vineyards was the rotation
of that before sanders sold it in 2005.
while many may only know of that winery
in peru new locations have started to
pop up
we wanted people to have a touch of
tuscany
a touch of italy and really not have to
travel too far
to visit sanders family winery has an
amazing view of mount charleston from
the other side that we see
in las vegas right next door to us is a
pistachio farm
you'll enter into the winery in through
the
courtyard through our amphitheater where
we actually do shows
and there is some history too there's
the original winery that i started
is parum valley winery then there is uh
artesian cellars and there's a stonewise
meadery
we do white wines we do red wines rose
wines
even champagne wine tasting is free and
bottles range between 10 and 16
you can get the most perfect photo you
want no matter where you are whether
it's in front of our statue
at the entrance whether it's the
entrance to the
amphitheater and the winery just the
building itself
is tuscan provincial the winery doesn't
sell food you can bring your own and
pets are also welcome next rocky theis
takes us to the summer setup
at the bellagio allow me to introduce
you to gaia the goddess of earth she has
brought
a beautiful new summer display to the
bellagio conservatory celebrating
our ecosystem all the details coming up
it's that time of year again the
bellagio conservatory has revealed its
summer display that's right and it's
celebrating our beautiful planet
rocky has stopped by to give us a
preview
and make sure to tag any of your photos
at 8 news now
thanks for watching and have a great
night
it's that time of year again the
bellagio conservatory has revealed its
summer display that's right and it's
celebrating our beautiful planet
rocky thea stopped by to give us a
preview i am so happy to be back at the
bellagio conservatory where we're
showing off the new summer display i
feel like it's been a while and
now i'm at tulum mexico is that right
maybe tulum mexico maybe something a
little scandinavian maybe a little
rainforesty
this is called eco a season of earthly
awareness and we really want you to take
away whatever you whatever you want to
take away from it
this bed represents air and wind we have
earth represented here
water which is a bellagio trademark and
fire behind us
so what went behind designing this one
in particular what's new
so this is a 90 new exhibit we do have
some pieces that we've repurposed from
other exhibits which is
really kind of what we're all about yeah
but this was a year and a half in the
making we actually started designing
this
quite a long time ago and it's evolved
as we've gone along
and really become something very
magnificent it is beautiful and you
mentioned that the sustainability you
mentioned you're repurposing
your repurposing items here so let me
move over here to leslie to talk about
the sustainability efforts
here at the bellagio and mgm resort yes
we're very excited to welcome back our
sustainability initiative at mgm resorts
international
what that means is we try to use
live material as much as possible we
have a lot of trees around the perimeter
of the conservatory that have been
residents for five or
more years so any and some smaller
shrubs that we've had since
last summer so anytime that we can reuse
or repurpose things we do
if things are not up to standard to
repurpose then we separate them from
their
pots and they go into a
composting facility out in north las
vegas they're turned in the heat
and then turned into mulch and packaged
for local landscapers to purchase
see that's why i love coming to talk to
you guys because you know besides coming
through and walking
and taking photos and enjoying the
display we get to hear the behind the
scenes and take a real
deeper look what did you call it an up
close magic we call it the up close
magic and
the closer you get to any of these
displays the more kind of involved and
the deeper the guest experience gets
it is incredible so let's talk about
leslie the fact that we are now it's
june 1st we don't have to wear masks
no social distancing 100 capacity yes
so we're very excited to welcome
everyone back 24 hours a day using any
point of entry that they choose
to get that perfect shot all right ed
and leslie thank you guys for inviting
us down you guys have to come enjoy this
through august correct
august 28th august 28th it is beautiful
here i'll send it back to you
a new exhibit is now open at the
bellagio gallery of fine arts
leather throwers will highlight artists
who have utilized imagery and the
personalities of boxing
to create sculptures paintings and
drawings several las vegas collectors
have loaned
their pieces to the exhibit for the very
first time leather throwers will be on
display starting friday until
august 22nd at the bellagio gallery of
fine arts
and we can't forget of course the most
popular place to take a photo the
welcome to las vegas sign designed in
1959
it has drawn large crowds ever since the
25 foot tall welcome sign has become one
of the city's most iconic landmarks
and one of the best selfie spots in town
thanks for watching destination vegas
and make sure to tag any of your photos
at 8 news now
thanks for watching and have a great
[Music]
night
you
you